AROUND WITH THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
AND THAT IS THE "ANGLE."
AND OUR NEXT GUEST REVEALS WHICH
RIVAL THE TRUMP TEAM IS MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT.
JOINING US NOW IS RUDY GIULIANI.
ATTORNEY FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
FORMER PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
HIMSELF.
RUDY, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> NICE TO SEE YOU.
>> Laura: IS THE PRESIDENT
SHAKING IN HIS BOOTS?
HE DOESN'T WEAR BOOTS.
SHAKING IN HIS -- I DON'T KNOW,
O SHOES OF COME OVER
KAMALA HARRIS?
>> HE'S NOT SHAKING AT ALL ABOUT
KAMALA HARRIS OR ANY OF THEM.
THE PRESIDENT REALIZES THERE'S
GOING TO BE A CANDIDATE, WE
DON'T KNOW WHO IT IS, AND THEY
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE ALL
THESE CRAZY CHARGES.
BUT I THINK IS PRETTY
COMFORTABLE.
I AM, CERTAINLY COMES WITH A VAC
OF THEY HAVE GONE SO FAR TO THE
LEFT.
KAMALA HARRIS IS IN FAVOR OF
OPEN BORDERS.
WHAT KIND OF PROSECUTOR SHE IS
IF SHE IS IN FAVOR OF OPEN
BORDERS.
IF YOU ARE IN FAVOR OF OPEN
BORDERS, YOU MUST BE IN FAVOR OF
OPEN DOORS.
LET EVERYBODY END.
LET'S NOT FIND OUT WHO THEY ARE
OR IDENTIFY THEMSELVES.
SHE'S IN FAVOR OF LEAVE TERM
ABORTION.
LATE TERM MEANING THE DAY BEFORE
THE BABY IS BORN.
WE CAN GO ON AND ON.
HIGH TAXES.
SHE DOES A LITTLE BETTER JOB
THAN SOME OF THEM, LIKE WARREN
AND BERNIE, OF DISGUISING
HERSELF AS NOT AS QUITE
LEFT-WING.
BUT WHEN YOU EXAMINE HER
POSITIONS, SHE'S VERY, VERY LEFT
WING.
I THINK SHE IS THE FLAVOR OF THE
MONTH BECAUSE JOE COULD NOT
DEFEND HIMSELF AND IT WAS KIND
OF PATHETIC.
SHE EVISCERATED HIM AND I
THOUGHT IT WASN'T WITH VERY
MUCH.
AND I THINK THAT WE GOT A VERY,
VERY BIG SIGNAL FROM MICHELLE.
THAT WAS DEFINITELY CALCULATED.
YOU SAW THAT.
I MEAN, YOU POINTED IT OUT
BEAUTIFULLY.
MICHELLE IS A VERY SMART WOMAN,
WHATEVER ELSE SHE HAS.
>> Laura: RUDY, SHE COULD HAVE
SAID, I'M NOT TAKING SIDES HERE
ON THE PRESIDENTIAL CONTEST, BUT
WE KNOW JOE BIDEN VERY WELL.
JOE AND JILL WERE REALLY CLOSE
TO US, SERVING WITH THEM FOR
EIGHT YEARS, NOT A RACIST BONE
IN HIS BODY.
>> THAT IS EASY TO SAY.
>> Laura: SHE WENT OUT OF
HER -- I THINK SHE WENT OUT OF
HER WAY, BOTH OF THEM, NOT TO
SAY THAT.
YOU CAN'T -- YOU DON'T HEAR A
PEEP OUT OF BARACK OBAMA UNLESS
IT IS A SIDESWIPE EYE DROP
WITHOUT REALLY MENTIONING HIM BY
NAME.
I HAVE FOUND THAT TO BE -- I
KIND OF FOUND THAT TO BE
GRACELESS ON THE PART OF THE
OBAMAS.
>> AT A BARE MINIMUM, BIDEN IS
ENTITLED TO, "HE'S NOT A
RACIST."
ALSO, HE'S NOT.
I HAVE A LOT OF ISSUES WITH
BIDEN, INCLUDING WHAT APPEARS TO
BE A LOT OF CORRUPTION IN CHINA
AND UKRAINE.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS -- MILLIONS
ONE PLACE, BILLIONS OTHER PLACE,
WHILE HE'S NEGOTIATING FOR
AMERICA.
HIS SON IS PULLING DOWN MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND JOE WAS TAKING
HIM THERE ON AIR FORCE TWO.
COME ON.
THAT WAS ONE OF US, WE'D BE
INDICTED BY NOW.
BUT I BELIEVE THE DEMOCRATS
AREN'T TOUCHING THAT YET.
THEY ARE TRYING TO TAKE THEM OUT
ON HIS LACK OF CONFIDENCE.
>> Laura: RUDY, THEY SEEM
VERY, AND SURPRISINGLY,
UNPREPARED.
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN PREPARED
FOR INCOMING FROM SOMEONE THEY
KNOW IT IS CLOSE WITH THE
OBAMAS.
>> LET'S FACE IT, JOE IS NEVER
BEEN A GOOD CANDIDATE.
I KNOW -- SHE'S NOT THAT BRIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THAT, IT
HAPPENS TO BE TRUE.
EVERYONE ALWAYS SAYS COME ALL,
HE'S FUNNY, HE'S UNCLE JOE.
THE FACT IS, HE'S NOT THE
BRIGHTEST BULB --
>> Laura: HE'S A BACK SLAPPER
TYPE.
A SHOULDER GRABBER.
>> HE'S NOT THAT SMART.
>> Laura: RUDY, JILL SPOKE OUT
TONIGHT --
>> THE REST OF THE PEOPLE ARE
SMART.
OBAMA IS SMART.
MICHELLE IS VERY WICKED SMART.
THEY ALSO REALIZE HE'S NOT UP TO
IT.
THEY WANT TO END.
I THINK THEY FEEL THAT JOE IS
GOING TO SELF IMPLODE AT SOME
POINT.
>> Laura: JILL BIDEN SPOKE OUT
TONIGHT AND IF THEY WERE CLEARLY
STONED AND
ILL-PREPARED FOR THIS ATTACK.
LET'S WATCH.
>> BIG A SURPRISE FOR YOU SO
FAR?
>> THE BIGGEST SURPRISE, I
THINK, WAS THE DEBATES.
I THINK PROBABLY KAMALA WAS A
LITTLE BIT OF A SURPRISE.
I THINK THAT IS A BIG SURPRISE
OF FIVE.
>> Laura: AGAIN.
HOW ARE YOU NOT PREPARED FOR
THAT?
THAT IS DISQUALIFYING IN AND OF
ITSELF.
>> OF COURSE IT IS.
IF YOU ARE NOT PREPARED FOR
KAMALA, ARE YOU PREPARED FOR --
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR KIM JONG UN
AND PUTIN AND PEOPLE IN CHINA?
[LAUGHS]
>> Laura: NO, THEY MAKE TOO
MUCH MONEY IN CHINA.
>> HONESTLY, JOE IS NOT
PREPARED.
THAT IS A SAD TRUTH ABOUT HIM.
>> Laura: RUDY, WE GOT OF A
LOT OF OTHER TOPICS WE WANT TO
GET TO.
WE DESTROY THAT TOPIC.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> Laura: I WANT TO GET TO
WHAT ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR SAID
ABOUT MUELLER'S UPCOMING
TESTIMONY NEXT WEEK.
WATCH.
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTED TO SEE HIM
SUBPOENAED BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT SERVES ANY PURPOSE DRAGON
BOB MUELLER UP IF HE IN FACT
IT'S GOING TO STICK TO THE
REPORT.
IT SEEMS TO ME THE ONLY REASON
FOR DOING THAT IS TO CREATE SOME
KIND OF PUBLIC SPECTACLE AND IF
BOB DECIDES THAT HE DOESN'T WANT
TO BE SUBJECT TO THAT, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WOULD
CERTAINLY BACK HIM.
>> Laura: WHAT YOU MAKE OF
THOSE COMMENTS?
>> I THINK THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL REALIZES THIS
HAS GONE WAY BEYOND WHAT
NORMALLY HAPPENS THAT WAY BEYOND
THE BOUNDS OF ETHICS AND
DISCUSSING THE FACTS ABOUT
SOMEBODY ABOUT WHOM YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO BRING CHARGES.
8400 PLUS PAGE REPORT, TEN
MINUTE SORT OF SUGGESTED
PRESS CONFERENCE, AND NOW WE
WILL REPEAT IT ALL WITH THIS
KIND OF GLORIFIED TESTIMONY?
I THINK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
FROM A POLITICAL POINT OF VIEW,
I ALMOST LIKE IT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT THE REPUBLICANS
HAVE A LOT OF GOOD QUESTIONS TO
ASK MUELLER.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE A VERY HARD
TIME ANSWERING THEM.
I THINK THE NET OF THIS IS GOING
TO BE THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
HAVE MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT
MUELLER AFTER IT'S OVER THEM
BEFORE THEY GO IN.
I CAN SEE WHY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND I WAS IN
HIS POSITION, I'D BE VERY CONCEN
HIS POSITION, I'D BE VERY CONCED
ABOUT HOW THIS IS REALLY
DOING SOMETHING TERRIBLY
UNETHICAL, THAT PROSECUTORS ARE
TAUGHT, YOU NEVER SHOULD DO.
YOU SHOULD NEVER TALK ABOUT A
CASE WHEN YOU DECLINE
PROSECUTION.
EVER, EVER, EVER.
>> Laura: WE WILL GET INTO
THIS TOPIC LATER IN THE SHOW BUT
I DID WANT TO GET YOUR TAKEN
THOUGHTS ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH JEFFREY EPSTEIN, HE PLED
NOT GUILTY TO CHARGES OF
SEX TRAFFICKING MINORS.
BREATHTAKINGLY HIDEOUS
ALLEGATIONS.
DID YOU KNOW HIM?
DID YOU HAVE ANY INTERACTIONS
WITH HIM EVER?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
I DON'T A MEMBER OF HER MEETING
WITH HIM.
HIS FACE LOOKS A LITTLE FAMILIAR
BUT IT MAY BE BECAUSE I'VE SEEN
THEM ON TELEVISION.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT I KNOW HIM.
HE'S A REAL CLOSE FRIEND OF
BILL CLINTON.
HE'S THE ONE WHO TRAVEL ON
PLANES WITH HIM, WENT ALL OVER
WITH HIM.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT BILL CLINTON
WAS INVOLVED IN ANY WAY BUT HE'S
THE ONE WHO WAS REALLY CLOSE TO
HIM.
I CAN'T IMAGINE I EVER HAD MUCH
TO DO WITH ANYTHING.
I DON'T RECALL EVER HAVING
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THEM.
>> Laura: LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE
CLEARLY AFTER THIS ALEX ACOSTA
LABOR SECRETARY FOR THE
PRESIDENT WITH EFFECTIVELY DEAL,
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT TONIGHT?
>> MY VIEW IS SOMEBODY CHARGED
WITH THE THINGS HE IS CHARGED
WITH, YOU THROW THE MAXIMUM
PENALTY AT HIM.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE DECIDED AS
U.S. ATTORNEY.
I DON'T WANT TO SECOND-GUESS
THAT.
MY KNEE-JERK REACTION TO IT IS
THAT THE GUY SHOULD BE IN JAIL
FOR A LONG TIME.
GIVEN WHAT I KNOW PUBLICLY, AND
HAVE TO PUT IN THE CAVEAT,
EVERYONE IS PRESUMED INNOCENT.
>> Laura: ONE FINAL THOUGHT,
RUDY, QUESTION, NANCY PELOSI
NANCY PELOSI SPOKE OUT TODAY ON
THE SENSES CITIZENSHIP QUESTION
AND MADE AN OUTRAGEOUS WIPE --
MORE THAN A SWIPE -- AT
THE PRESIDENT.
WATCH.
>> THIS IS ABOUT KEEPING -- YOU
KNOW THAT HIS HAT, MAKE AMERICA
WHITE AGAIN.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE, CERTAIN PEOPLE, ARE
COUNTED.
IT'S REALLY DISGRACEFUL.
IT'S NOT WHAT OUR FOUNDERS HAD
IN MIND.
WHO ARE WE?
WHAT IS AMERICA?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S WRONG
WITH HER.
THE QUESTION IS, NANCY, WHETHER
YOU ARE A CITIZEN.
WE HAVE WHITE CITIZENS, BLACK
CITIZENS, WE HAVE HISPANIC
CITIZENS, CHINESE -- IT'S
WHETHER YOU ARE A CITIZEN.
>> Laura: WHY DID SHE SAY IT,
RUDY?
GOING BACK TO MY "ANGLE."
THIS IS BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY
TO TAKE OUT THE PRESIDENT.
THEY WANT TO DIVIDE THIS
COUNTRY, THEY WANTED HER AND
WHITE AGAINST BLACK,
HISPANIC AGAINST BLACK, WHITE
AGAINST -- I MEAN, IT IS A
CYNICAL, HORRIBLE STRATEGY.
>> EVERY SINGLE THING THAT IS
DONE, WHETHER IT RELATES TO
ANYTHING LIKE THAT OR NOT, THEY
WILL INTERPRET THAT WAY.
IT'S LIKE A TALKING POINT THEY
JUST REPEAT.
THERE IS NOTHING RACIAL ABOUT
ASKING SOMEONE WHETHER THEY ARE
A CITIZEN.
IT IS LIKE SEEKING
IDENTIFICATION BEFORE YOU VOTE.
THAT'S RACIAL?
>> Laura: SHE KNOWS IT.
SHE SANG IT ANYWAY.
>> YOU HAVE TO PRODUCE
IDENTIFICATION TO GET ON AN
AIRPLANE.
>> Laura: NANCY PELOSI'S MIND.
SHE IS DOING THIS VERY REASON.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT TRUMP
GAINING EVEN A FIVE PERCENTAGE
POINT AMONG AFRICAN-AMERICAN
VOTERS BECAUSE IT'S A GREAT
ECONOMIC RECORD HE SAT WITH
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
I THINK THEY ARE PANICKED ABOUT
THAT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO -- THEY WANT
TO DIVIDE THE COUNTRY ON RACIAL
LINES.
I THINK IT'S DISGUSTING.
EVERYONE IS DOING BETTER IN THIS
ECONOMY, EVERYBODY.
>> THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE RAN AN
'16 SAID TAKE A CHANCE ON ME,
YOU CAN'T DO ANY WORSE.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE DOING BETTER
THAN THEY HAVE EVER DONE, ALL OF